it's pretty clear that technical
innovation
is what's driving us forward and
engineers are the building blocks of
that innovation they're the ones who are
building the technology
and they're also the scarcest resource
in the valley
[Music]
so badish i want to go back to your high
school days you're very involved with
model united nations
you're you grew up in tanbul right in
turkey
gave me a little bit of background as to
who you are who is baris
yeah um thanks for asking about that and
i also believe you know how people grew
up who who they looked up to
what they were involved early early on
really influences who they are
so whenever i meet with people that's a
question i always ask
uh for me um i got really influenced by
my mother growing up
uh she was an executive recruiter and
also an mba professor
so it's really all about professional
development
and that was um something i always
talked about
and during high school i started a
non-profit to help
underprivileged high school students who
were academically really strong
to develop critical social and
professional skills
and we use model united nations as a
tool to support that
uh starting to first do model young
conferences in turkish because most of
the people who needed the most
didn't speak english really well in
turkey
and we made it three four people we grew
that non-profit to be a national
organization
and i worked with the united nations to
actually
further grow that and was extremely
rewarding work
i i still get chills when i i look back
to some of the work we've done
if you know for context i'm i'm a huge
fan of modern nations i was actually the
secretary general of our school's
model united nations conference um in
the middle east modern united nations
that we called it
but talk to me give me a bit of context
what is so special about model united
nations and how did you leverage
the incredible program that it provides
to help
support your mission yeah
um the the thing that we realize uh
that made it hard for a lot of young
turkish people to speak up
practice public speaking discussion is
they were worried
of being judged based on their opinions
uh the beautiful thing about model
united nations is
you're not representing yourself when
you're speaking you're representing the
views of the country ambassador of a
country
so when you're speaking up no one can
judge you based on
what you are thinking and what you are
seeing because there is a layer of
abstraction between you yourself
and what you are saying and we realize
that later that layer of abstraction
really gives people further confidence
to speak up
and as they get into these conferences
and start speaking up as like a
french or american or israeli delegates
over time
they start speaking more of their
opinion and they build that confidence
right so you from there you find
yourself at stanford you're getting your
bachelor's degree there
you're very very involved with social
entrepreneurship right you even
went on to become an instructor for a
course that is centered around
around innovation right i think it was
urban i it was
with some code afterwards yeah
um so that that class is a really funny
story because that class didn't existed
we end up starting that class
but to maybe refine the history a little
bit um
i chose stanford because i've always
been very entrepreneurial and knew i
wanted to start something of my own and
when i started stanford
and a few weeks into school i became
really close friends with this guy ryan
breslow who was living a few rooms next
to me at my freshman door
he had an incredible story super
inspiring you know he started buying and
selling domains when he was like 10 to
11 years old
built websites throughout high school
and we decided to give it a shot to
building a company together
so our first thanksgiving break we
didn't go back home instead we stayed in
our
dorm and did cold call sales and ended
up bootstrapping a business together
and we grew that on the side of school
and going into our second year we sold
that company
and when we sold that company uh i ended
up using some of the proceeds from that
to start angel investing in my friends
companies
which ended up exposing me to a lot of
really smart ambitious stanford friends
who had crazy ideas and during those
conversations
because this is it's just so inspiring
to you to hear you're a freshman you are
sitting in the dorms you meet a guy
a friend three rooms down thanksgiving
break everybody goes home no no you're
sitting there doing cold calls
and then come next by the following year
you already sell that business and
instead of just you know going and
partying and wasting all that money you
go and you're investing
and your friends as a sophomore in
college that is so amazing
yeah thank you that's very kind of free
and i think
i got investing uh thanks to my current
co-founder armand
so armand has also an amazing story and
starting his freshman year at stanford
worst classmates he was actually one of
the first 10 people i met at school
he was always being super helpful to all
our entrepreneurial friends
building companies on any way he can
and i really looked up to how supportive
he was to our peers and including myself
and ryan
and when ryan started his second company
bolt
our man was actually his first investor
and i was really inspired by this notion
of
being a long-term partner to people you
want to build with
and investing was a way to formalize
that partnership
a way to say hey we want to win together
we're on the same team now
and i really like that notion and that's
what led me to actually get them to
invest
wow okay so and again you're saying
getting into investing
you're a sophomore at stanford which is
after you've already
gone through that you know being an
entrepreneur and doing cold calls
yourself selling that company and then
going to investing talk to me a little
bit about
why you stayed with investing and how
does that play into this new idea
called human capital which is way more
than just another
investment firm yeah so i actually did
i didn't see that staying with investing
as i said investing was a tool to
partner with people for the long term
and while i was finishing stanford i
realized look i have a lot of really
smart friends not all
many of them are starting companies a
lot of them are actually starting their
careers working at companies
right and as myself and our month
and the question is there a way we can
partner with
people throughout their career no matter
what they're doing
and build the notion of hey let's win
together with a much larger group of
people not just friends starting
companies
and we built human capital based on that
idea
the idea of let's identify really smart
ambitious engineers
and be their lifelong partner and help
them whether they want to join companies
or start companies and how does that
formally look so it's an amazing thought
we're going to help engineers be you
know be their partner along the journey
which is non-linear and it's not
you know it's a it's a lifetime of a
partnership and not just you know
a one investment that you're in you're
out
what does that mean to you to form that
partnership and how do you tangibly do
that as a form of a committee or a form
of a company
yeah it we we we refer human capital as
a venture firm
and it's a mix of a venture capital fund
and a talent agency for ambitious
engineers and founders
it's really based on this core belief
that great engineers
are fundamental to every
industry-defining technology company
right and we partner with great
engineers
for their entire career where at any
given point they can come to us and say
look
i'm looking for a new company to join
and we'll have
some of the most exciting companies in
the valley including some really stalled
uh companies started by experience
founders available to them that we can
introduce
at one point engineers can come to us
and say look i have an idea i'm thinking
of starting my own company
will constantly investing in their ideas
and we also like to partner with
founders who share that same belief that
engineers are fundamental to building
great companies
and we partner with them as investors
and we help them build and scale their
engineering teams
so you say engineer why what is it about
this
engineering skill set or that profession
that that draws you to focus on that
demographic
being in silicon valley being at the
core of technology
it's pretty clear that technical
innovation is
what's driving us forward and engineers
are the building blocks of that
innovation they're the ones who are
building the technology
and they're also the scarcest resource
in the valley
if you go and talk to any founder out
there and ask
what's your biggest need they will say
they need more
top tell quality engineers on their team
right
right so so by harnessing that scarcity
you're you're you're essentially
understanding that
you know this this is what's going to
change the world this is what's going to
move it forward and you want to be at
the forefront of that
but buddy you can't possibly take on
as a partner every single engineer that
you meet and even though there is a lot
of scarcity there
are a lot of engineers and i'm sure that
there are a lot of engineers that come
to you and say
we want to be your friend or we want to
be a part of your amazing community so
how do you even go about
you know because you're not sitting
there and trying to invest in them and
doing
you know due diligence process on the
company sometimes you have to start to
do
a due diligence process on who they are
right and more of a
is this a human being that i want to
partner with in the long term
yeah actually we we don't all our due
diligence process even when we're
investing
begins with what you just said is this a
founder is this an engineer we want to
partner for the long term
and the engineers we work with we refer
them as our members
because membership um implies that this
is going to be a long-term relationship
right um and for our members to also
remind all our services are fully free
for members
so they don't pass anything for either
connecting us to companies or any other
way we support them and the way we
started uh growing our membership has
been at universities
uh early on we built uh student teams
at top universities where uh students
who became
our ambassadors referred as some of
their most talented peers
as we met more and more uh talented
engineers and supported them they
started referring us
their friends and more and after a while
this fly flywheel started growing so
you know over the last few years we've
been meeting with thousands of engineers
every year
and some of those people then you know
became people in two
three years into their career they
started referring their friends
that they work with their colleagues
and then as we grow our team and group
our brand more and more people start
reaching out to us as well
so um for us it's really when we meet
someone new it's really about getting to
know them
and understanding their background who
they're as a person
their experiences their ambitions what
they want to do with their career
and then it's a process of figuring out
how can we be most helpful to them now
and how can we be most helpful for them
long term i mean but i have to say that
you know i had the pleasure of being now
at stanford and in the valley for about
a year and a half and experiencing both
the curiosity and
the passion but at the same time the
competitiveness
and the in the intensity that every
single person brings to the table
and i'm so inspired to hear about your
take on relationship building
and this sort of this long-term
partnership instead of this you know
single deal breaking moment that you're
deciding to be in there or not
now i want to have a more you know a
discussion about
you know our humanity and you know i'm
looking at myself as a student at
stanford
a rising entrepreneur myself in the next
few years and i'm looking at all my
friends as entrepreneurs
looking at all the amazing people that
you've worked with and that you are
working with now
what are some key things that we should
be keeping in mind as we go about
our journeys and who are the people that
we are partnering with and what should
be our core values as we as we go
forward in this very competitive space
yeah i think that that that's a really
good question and
if i were to kind of reframe a little
bit um
i think that one of the most important
thing begins with people being
aware about what their values are
actually
you know with that became a question we
started asking when we were growing our
own team
and you'll be really surprised by a
number of people who say hey what are
your core values and they're like
actually never talk of that um so i
think it's really important first
people to be aware what their core
values are
and why those are things they really
care about
and are there certain values they want
to potentially change and grow and be
different
over time and once people are very
clear on their own core values then
building
their career path and making decisions
based on those
become much easier um so i think it's
it's really
not about choosing right core values for
everyone but it's more people being
aware of what their values are
right but at the end it's still it's
difficult because
we go through this competitive landscape
and sometimes the
temptations to you know get ahead
at the expense sometimes of others and
naturally in competition so
what where do you see success playing
in in with with that so i think you ask
a very important question about
competition and people being very
competitive and i would love to reframe
that question
because competition implies two things
one there is an objective score
of winning and two it's most likely a
zero-sum game
and i actually have problems with both
of those implications
because in life there isn't an objective
score of success there are many proxies
to success
but you choose which proxy to follow
based on your core values
therefore it goes back to what we just
discussed people being clear on their
core values
so they can define what success means
for themselves
and then focus on competing on that
level
and the second thing it implies is when
you are winning someone else is losing
and that's actually something i strongly
disagree with
because the best version of the world is
when you're winning with your peers when
you're winning with your friends when
you're all successful together
and when you look at technology right
like when
when google is getting more valuable
microsoft is not losing value
right like it's not a zero-sum game
people are winning together
and that's the beautiful thing about the
ecosystem we're in
and why i think people are so supportive
with each other is that we can all win
together
and create a better world together and
that's something really exciting to me
i think that's just wonderful what are
you passionate about so
of everything that you do working with
entrepreneurs and engineers
investing seeing amazing amazing people
thrive what are you
deeply passionate about yeah
i really love people i really love
uh people and like supporting people
helping people grow
empowering people i think that kind of
influence i mentioned earlier on
through my mother and growing up around
like empowering others
is something really stuck with me and
also being like a
super extroverted person uh i think it
became easier
at stanford everyone knew the best place
to find me was
koopa cafe because i will basically not
go to class sit at koopa and grab couple
with my friends all day long
uh so that kind of love of people is
something i really enjoy and care about
which makes my job really really fun
because all i get to do is to meet
really smart people all day long
i just love it and i'm so thankful
to be a part of the journey and to and
and for us to have met
through our good friend santiago and and
i hope to continue being a part of this
and and continue growing with you so
before we leave
i want to thank you again for being so
generous with your time and i'd love to
ask for three words that you would
describe yourself as or if i would ask
other people that you invested in
how would they describe barish
so one pic one one thing that will come
up is ambitious
we really want to do big things um
the second is um
i think mix of like people focused and
passionate yeah
uh just uh outgoing people focus
passionate
um and i think the third is more like
growth mindset and curious continuously
want to learn and grow more
i love it but thank you so so much this
was just wonderful
and i'm sure this is what this will be
incredibly insightful for
for myself it already was but for my
friends and my peers
listening to your take on on your
relationship building and competition
i think that's really inspiring so thank
you
i hope so and thanks for hosting me this
was really fun
of course take care